a federal judge says President Trump
cannot deny asylum to migrants who
crossed the border illegally the
President issued a proclamation that
anyone who doesn't go to a u.s. port of
entry would be ineligible for asylum now
in his ruling overnight the judge wrote
whatever the scope of the President's
authority he may not rewrite the
immigration laws to impose a condition
that Congress has expressly forbidden
Paula Reed is here Paula good morning
Wow it looks like this judge's ruling is
just the latest setback for what a
president Trump's hardline stances on
immigration it is this is a blow to the
Trump administration they want to revise
the asylum system over the past five
years we've seen pretty much a
three-fold increase in the number of
people seeking asylum you touch US soil
you claim asylum then you're protected
from deportation and entitled to a
process and the president argues that
the system is being abused they deter
people from coming here so this means if
you're part of the caravan you can seek
asylum what he's trying to say is you
have to go to a specific point of entry
because right now people come across the
border or anywhere they step on US soil
they say I want to seek asylum but they
want to deter people from doing that as
part of an effort to deter people
overall from coming here illegally but
right now the judge said look you can't
rewrite the laws that's up to Congress
this is only a temporary order though
correct exactly and the judge will want
to hear additional arguments on this and
we've seen this before with what the
president's trying to do with the travel
ban sanctuary cities and daca sometimes
he will subsequently revised to try to
meet what the judge wants